[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elle annonce dans sa tournée qu'elle va
ressenter tout ses tubes ça veut dire et
4 heures elle a confirmé son retour en
postant une photo de sa tournée mondiale
baptisée de célébration tour regardez
elle aurait dû appeler ça elle aurait dû
appeler sage
vont jusqu'à 500 dollars est-ce que vous
savez pourquoi 400 les assurances ont
tellement peur que comme pour Justin
Bieber elle passe trois dates et
qu'après bourré machin qu'elle parce que
sa dernière tournée elle en a beaucoup
annulé que du coup du covid
a tourné en 2020 ici au Grand Rex
Madonna les premières dates et les
assurée les dernières elle a pas pu à
cause des conditions
parfois les gens étaient dans la salle
elle est pas venue mais oui et donc
l'Eurovision en Israël où elle a été
absolument odieuse mais ça reste Madonna
donc voilà le concert en France je vais
vous dire qu'il a été soldes out parle
pas anglais vider 5 minutes ça reste
qu'elle Madonna c'est hallucinant donc
le spectacle de voyage artistique
paraît-il de Madonna à travers que
quatre dessinées des décennies pardon et
rendre hommage à la ville de New York
elle passera par Paris des 12 et 13
novembre elle va interpréter ses plus
grands hits et voilà les places ça va
jusqu'à 400 €, je trouve ça où elle est
incroyable c'est que si l'histoire est
vraie c'est vraiment ça c'est un 31
c'est ce que raconte à 31 tu joues un
peu avec des jeux pour boire tu es
bourré si elles ont joué à action ou
vérité et elle elle a la préaction et le
mec lui dit action tu perds tu fais une
tournée mondiale elle a perdu elle l'a
fait c'est pas un génie ça peut s'y
croire ou pas c'est du storytelling ça
il y a 40 ans quand elle a commencé sa
carrière nous a dit qu'elle était
arrivée avec un dollar à New York mais
c'est vrai évidemment
sur les réseaux sociaux elle ne fait que
ça c'est de la mise en scène tout le
temps elle met un panier de basket si je
le mets je suis homosexuel le lendemain
elle va dire qu'elle boit du sang quel
snif du Popper elle ne fait que ça son
visage change elle est plus ça va plus
elle ressemble à offrir Bogdanov où on
sait pas trop et non mais c'est vrai non
mais la bonne nouvelle elle peut pas
chanter elle peut prendre un Afida
Turner en doublure
personne verra la différence peut
prendre
et juste
comme tous les gens qui ont gagné tant
d'argent pendant tant d'années elle a
besoin d'argent il y a pas longtemps à
gagner entre 100 à 150 millions de
dollars par an aujourd'hui elle en gagne
beaucoup moins ça fait 15 ans qu'elle a
pas fait un tube donc cette tournée elle
est importante mais c'est vrai et une
tournée en 15 jours prévu tout ça pardon
c'est quand on dit que les gens très
riches ont plus besoin d'argent c'est
pas vrai les gens très riches sont en
train de bien incroyable bien sûr Elton
John quand il a fait sa dernière tournée
pardon de vous le dire mais ça se
sentait qui se fait déchir il était au
piano tout le long c'est tout le long je
crois que c'est mes deux fois alors il
était assis il se lève
et hop il sera assez il chantait et il a
pris un million de dollars pour aller à
l'accord Arena pour une et il a même pas
dormi à Paris la prochaine avion est
rentré voilà et on peut pas lui en
vouloir il a chanté dans tous les pays
du monde il chante cette tube qu'il a
chanté mille fois mais ils ont besoin
d'une tout le monde a besoin
mais justement c'est ça qui est
intéressant c'est qu'elle a compris que
les dernières tournées n'avaient pas
fait recette parce que finalement elle a
monté sur scène elle s'est fait un petit
peu décrié parce que d'abord elle
chantait un peu faux il y avait beaucoup
de playback c'était un petit peu voilà
elle a annulé plusieurs dates donc là je
trouve que le fait de faire une tournée
où elle va chanter exclusivement c'est
hit tous les tubes de ce que les gens
adorent est-ce que les gens attendent
c'est une super bonne idée effectivement
ça fait plusieurs mois que ça se prépare
l'espace de buzz ou ça monte sur
Instagram et d'ailleurs là elle se sert
à nouveau des réseaux sociaux parce
qu'elle a enlevé toutes les photos de
son Instagram elle en a mis que 4 sur la
tour de mon gars vraiment l'histoire de
ce que j'aime avec les Américains c'est
que les Américains c'est de la vente
donc ils viennent il y a pas de première
partie il y a pas de rappel ils viennent
ils chantent leur tube et il se cassent
en France vous allez voir un chanteur
alors il a huit tubes et venez en fait
je vais vous chanter mes nouvelles
créatures que j'ai fait un acoustique et
vous aurez peut-être un de mes tubes à
la fin enfin pardon mais ça me fait
chier parce que tu vois ils veulent pas
chanter ce qu'on veut bah non tu parles
des artistes
vous souhaitez aller voir Bob Dylan
j'attendais
surtout Sardou je m'attends à tout ce
qui m'a dit entre les chansons
Michel Sardou oui j'ai déjà pris mes
places bébé
excuse-moi
donc je pensais que Mathieu était plus
Madonna que Michel Sardou tu pensais
qu'il était mort